2 c'est pas bien de jeter des objets
tipoli dans l'eau la leçon semblait bien
apprise dans les années 90 pourtant
aujourd'hui entre 8 et 12 millions de
tonnes de plastique termine dans les
océans chaque année pour que l'opinion
s'émeuve de la pollution du plastique en
mer il a fallu une image choc en 1995
celle d'une tortue luth morte
les sacs plastiques sont alors la
deuxième cause de mortalité de cette
espèce protégée
d'amore arrive quand il ya suffisamment
d'acier qu'on fait notre région elle
meurt de dénutrition et quelquefois
aussi le plastique créer des légions de
l'estomac et la chamane une infection
généralisée
le constat dans les années 90 il faut
limiter les rejets de plastique
les associations comme la fondation
hulot sont à l'oeuvre pour diffuser le
message ne s'est pas bien de jeter des
objets qui peut lui dans l'eau pourquoi
c'est pas bien parce que sinon après ça
va ça va tuer les animaux
1ère et puis ensuite on va être tué le
même le plastique gagne les maires ils
s'accumulent en 2001 le navigateur
olivier de kersauzon crémiers cette
pollution de plus en plus courante lors
de ces traversées
on a l'impression que celle que cette
pollution va tourner et tourner et
tourner tourner journée elle façon
indestructible ça c'est terrible du
plastique qui tourne en mer et qui
persistent des centaines d'années avant
de se décomposer les particules se masse
jusqu'à créer un continent souvent par
lé deal de déchets et les gens pensent
qu'on peut marcher dessus voire même
habité dessus c'est pas ça du tout en
fait il ya une fine pellicule de
plastique sous la surface de l'eau qui
déstabilise toute la chaîne alimentaire
les microparticules de plastique sont
ingérés par les planctons eux mêmes
mangés par les poissons
et au bout de la chaîne alimentaire
l'homme reste à savoir quelles sont les
conséquences sur l'organisme
les recherches sont en cours
[Musique]